Elle est éclectique, je sais.
Cela va des éoliennes offshore à l'éducation des filles,
des alimentations riches en plantes à la technologie des panneaux solaires.
Analysons un peu cela.
A droite de l'écran, vous voyez des chiffres en gigatonnes,
soit des milliards de tonnes.
Cela représente la réduction équivalente en dioxyde de carbone
dans l'atmosphère
quand la solution est mise en œuvre à l'échelle mondiale durant 30 ans.
Quand nous pensons aux solutions climatiques,
nous pensons souvent à la production électrique.
Nous voyons les énergies renouvelables comme les solutions les plus importantes
et elles sont incroyablement importantes.
La première chose que l'on remarque avec cette liste,
c'est que seulement cinq des 20 solutions principales
sont liées à l'électricité.
Ce qui nous a surpris, honnêtement,
c'est que huit des 20 solutions sont liées au système alimentaire.
L'impact climatique de l'alimentation peut surprendre beaucoup de gens,
mais ces résultats montrent que nos décisions quotidiennes
quant à la nourriture produite, achetée et consommée
sont peut-être les contributions les plus importantes
de chaque individu pour inverser le réchauffement climatique.
Notre gestion du territoire est également très importante.
Protéger les forêts et les zones humides
sauvegarde, étend et crée de nouveaux puits de carbone
qui extraient directement du carbone.
Voilà comment le drawdown peut arriver.
En réunissant la nourriture et la gestion du territoire,
12 des 20 solutions sont liées à comment et pourquoi nous utilisons le territoire.
Cela change fondamentalement la réflexion traditionnelle
au sujet des solutions climatiques.
Mais considérons le début de la liste
car je crois que ce qu'il y a là pourrait vous surprendre.
La solution ayant le plus gros impact,
d'après cette analyse, serait la gestion de la réfrigération,
ou la gestion et l'élimination des hydrofluorocarbures, ou HFC,
qui sont utilisés dans les réfrigérateurs et les climatiseurs pour refroidir l'air.
Nous avons bien réussi avec le protocole de Montréal
à limiter la production de chlorofluorocarbures, CFC,
du fait de leur effet sur la couche d'ozone.
Mais ils ont été remplacés par les HFC,
dont l'effet de serre est des centaines ou des milliers de fois plus fort
que celui du dioxyde de carbone.
Cette réduction de 90 gigatonnes est une estimation prudente.
Si nous devions prendre en compte l'effet de l'accord de Kigali,
qui appelle à l'élimination des hydrofluorocarbures
et les remplacions avec des réfrigérants naturels qui existent aujourd'hui,
ce chiffre pourrait augmenter et atteindre 120 ou près de 200 gigatonnes
de gaz à effet de serre évités.
Vous êtes peut-être aussi surpris que nous l'étions.
Avant d'entrer dans les détails de solutions spécifiques,
vous vous demandez peut-être comment nous avons fait ces calculs.
Pour commencer, nous avons collecté beaucoup de données
et avons utilisé une analyse statistique pour établir des échelles
nous permettant de faire des choix raisonnables
pour chaque donnée d'entrée des modèles.
Nous avons choisi une approche conservative,
qui sous-tend tout le projet.
Toutes les données sont entrées dans le modèle,
estimées pour l'avenir de façon ambitieuse mais plausible
et comparées à ce que nous devrions quand même faire.
Par exemple, la réduction de 84 gigatonnes grâce aux éoliennes terrestres
découle de l'électricité générée par les parcs éoliens
qui serait autrement produite par des centrales à charbon ou au gaz.
Nous calculons tous les coûts
de construction et fonctionnement des centrales
et toutes les émissions générées.
Le même processus est utilisé
pour comparer le recyclage et l'enfouissement,
l'agriculture régénératrice et industrielle,
la protection et l'abattage de nos forêts.
Les résultats sont intégrés dans nos systèmes
pour éviter toute double comptabilisation
et additionner le tout pour voir si nous atteignons le drawdown.
Discutons de quelques solutions spécifiques.
Les panneaux solaires sont classés au 10ème rang.
Quand nous pensons aux panneaux solaires,
nous envisageons souvent un entrepôt à Miami couvert de panneaux solaires.
Mais ces solutions sont pertinentes dans des environnements urbains et ruraux,
des pays à revenus faibles et élevés,
et dont les bénéfices en entraînent d'autres.
Voici une famille sur une île de production de paille du lac Titicaca
recevant son premier panneau solaire.
Avant, du kérosène était utilisé pour la cuisine et l'éclairage,
du kérosène sur une île de paille.
En installant un panneau solaire, cette famille aide à réduire les émissions
mais garantit aussi la sûreté et la sécurité de son foyer.
Les forêts tropicales en disent long.
Protéger les territoires actuellement dégradés dans les tropiques
et permettre leur régénération naturelle
est la cinquième solution pour inverser le réchauffement climatique.
Nous pouvons voir les arbres comme des bâtons de carbone géants.
C'est le drawdown en action chaque année,
puisque le carbone est extrait de l'atmosphère par photosynthèse,
ce qui convertit le dioxyde de carbone
en biomasse végétale et en carbone dans le sol.
Nous devons repenser notre production de nourriture
pour la rendre plus régénératrice.
Il y a de nombreuses façons de faire cela et nous en avons étudié 13,
qui ne sont pas de nouvelles méthodes de production.
Elles ont été pratiquées durant des siècles, des générations.
Mais elles sont de plus en plus remplacées par l'agriculture moderne,
qui promeut le travail du sol, la monoculture
et l'utilisation d'engrais synthétiques et de pesticides qui dégradent le terrain
et le transforment en émetteur de gaz à effet de serre.
L'agriculture régénératrice, d'un autre côté,
restaure la santé et la productivité du sol,
augmente le rendement,
améliore la rétention d'eau,
profite aux petits exploitants comme aux grands producteurs
et retourne le carbone dans le sol.
C'est gagnant-gagnant-gagnant- gagnant-gagnant.
(Rires)
Et ce n'est pas que notre production
mais ce que nous consommons
qui a une grande incidence sur le réchauffement climatique.
Riche en plantes, ce n'est pas végétalien ou végétarien,
même si je salue ceux qui font ce choix.
C'est une alimentation saine en termes de quantités consommées
et en particulier, en quantité de viande consommée.
Dans les parties riches du monde,
nous surconsommons.
Cependant, les pays à bas revenus
affichent un apport insuffisant de calories et de protéines.
Il faut rééquilibrer cela
et c'est dans le rééquilibre
qu'une alimentation riche en plantes devient la 4ème solution
pour inverser le réchauffement climatique.
De plus, environ un tiers de la nourriture produite n'est pas mangée
et la nourriture gaspillée émet 8% des gaz à effet de serre.
Nous devons chercher où dans la chaîne logistique
ces pertes et gaspillages se produisent.
Dans les pays à bas revenus, après avoir quitté la ferme,
la nourriture est surtout gaspillée au début de la chaîne
du fait des défis liés à l'infrastructure et au stockage.
Les consommateurs ne gaspillent pas dans les pays à bas revenus
ayant du mal à nourrir leur population.
Dans le monde développé, après avoir quitté la ferme,
la nourriture est gaspillée à la fin de la chaîne
par les marchés et consommateurs
et la nourriture gaspillée finit à la décharge
où elle émet du méthane
en se décomposant.
C'est un problème de choix des consommateurs.
Ce n'est pas un problème lié à la technologie.
Éviter tout gaspillage alimentaire
est la troisième solution.
Mais voici ce qui est intéressant.
Quand nous considérons le système alimentaire entier
et nous instaurons toutes les solutions de production,
comme l'agriculture régénératrice,
adoptons une alimentation riche en plantes
et réduisons le gaspillage alimentaire,
notre recherche montre
que nous produirions assez de nourriture sur les terres agricoles actuelles
pour nourrir sainement, nutritivement la population mondiale croissante
jusqu'à 2050 et au-delà.
Nous n'avons pas besoin d'abattre des forêts pour produire de la nourriture.
Les solutions pour inverser le réchauffement climatique
sont les mêmes que celles pour l'insécurité alimentaire.
Une solution dont on ne parle souvent pas assez :
la planification familiale.
Offrir aux hommes et aux femmes le droit de choisir
quand, comment et si oui ou non ils veulent fonder une famille
grâce à des cliniques de santé de la reproduction, l'éducation,
l'accès à la contraception
et une liberté dénuée de persécution
peut diminuer la population mondiale estimée d'ici à 2050.
Cela implique une diminution de la demande
en électricité, nourriture, transport, bâtiments et toutes les autres ressources.
L'énergie et les émissions
utilisées pour satisfaire cette demande plus élevée
sont réduites en assurant le droit de l'Homme fondamental
qu'est le choix de quand, comment
et si oui ou non on veut fonder une famille.
Mais la planification familiale ne peut pas avoir lieu
sans une éducation de qualité
pour les filles à qui, actuellement, on en refuse l'accès.
Nous avons ici pris la liberté -
puisque l'influence d'une éducation universelle
et des ressources de planification familiale
sont si inextricablement liées -
de les dissocier.
Mais ensemble, l'éducation des filles et la planification familiale
sont la solution numéro un pour inverser le réchauffement climatique,
diminuant les gaz à effet de serre d'environ 120 milliards de tonnes.
Le drawdown est-il possible ?
La réponse est oui,
mais nous avons besoin des 80 solutions.
Il n'y a pas une ou un groupe de solutions miracles
qui nous y mèneront.
Les principales solutions nous mèneraient loin,
mais il n'y a pas de petite solution.
Nous avons besoin des 80.
Voici ce qui est génial :
nous voulons mettre ces solutions en œuvre
que le réchauffement climatique soit un problème ou non
car elles bénéficient au bien-être des êtres humains et de la planète.
L'électricité renouvelable offre
un accès à une énergie propre et abondante pour tous.
Une alimentation riche en plantes, moins de gaspillage
mène à une population mondiale saine avec assez de nourriture et d'aliments.
La planification familiale et l'éducation des filles ?
C'est une question de droits de l'Homme,
d'égalité des sexes.
C'est une question d'amélioration économique
et de droit de choisir.
C'est une question de justice.
L'agriculture régénératrice, la gestion des pâturages,
l'agroforesterie, le sylvopastoralisme
restaurent la santé des sols, profitent aux fermiers
et retournent le carbone dans le sol.
La protection de nos écosystèmes protège la biodiversité
et sauvegarde la santé planétaire
et l'oxygène que nous respirons.
Ses avantages tangibles pour toutes les espèces sont incalculables.
Un dernier point, car cela trotte probablement dans l'esprit de tous :
combien cela va-t-il coûter ?
Nous estimons que la mise en œuvre des 80 solutions
coûterait environ 29 000 milliards de dollars sur une période de 30 ans.
C'est environ 1 000 milliards par an.
Je sais que cela semble être beaucoup,
mais nous devons nous rappeler
que le PIB mondial est supérieur à 80 000 milliards par an
et l'estimation des économies liées à la mise en œuvre de ces solutions
est de 74 000 milliards de dollars, plus de deux fois le coût.
Ce sont des économies nettes de 44 000 milliards de dollars.
Le drawdown est possible.
Nous pouvons y arriver si nous le voulons.
Cela ne va pas coûter tant que ça et le retour sur investissement est énorme.
Voici la bonne surprise.
En mettant en œuvre ces solutions,
nous changeons notre façon de faire des affaires,
passant d'un système intrinsèquement d'exploitation et d'extraction
à une nouvelle norme naturellement réparatrice et régénératrice.
Nous devons revoir nos objectifs mondiaux,
aller au-delà de la durabilité
et vers la régénération
et, au passage, inverser le réchauffement climatique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)